dropped and judged on the way you look
in Hollywood and despite more stars
opening up about their plastic surgery
many more want to keep the procedures
top secret
oh she's don't see digs right there you
recognize that young talent yep it's
Katy Coco she was just 16 years old when
she hosted a show for us about stars
going under the knife well today the Big
Bang star is so open about getting a
little medical help herself and how she
just can't resist an occasional fast
food binge tonight I'll be going to in
and out and doing that one of their
grilled cheeses massive fries and a
shake that would be like a cheat for me
that's not the only chief
Kaylee's indulged in while rocking this
killer bod she casually confesses to
some plastic surgery saying quote years
ago I had my nose done recently I had a
filler in my line in my neck I've had
since I was 12 and my boobs best thing I
ever did I love them and I'm super happy
I would do it again in RP what do you
think so I get a nip-tuck well she
explains quote I don't think anyone
should do it for a man or anyone else
but if it makes you feel confident
that's amazing
but abs like these did not come from
lipo I realized I don't like running
that's my side refused to do it
I like spinning so I try and mix that in
and I do Pilates for a little while but
I didn't really fall in love with it so
when I found hot yoga I fell in love
with it I was like this is my thing
Kaylee tells women's health that hot
yoga is where she pride over her divorce
from Ryan Sweeting no one can tell cut
it just looked like sweat the 30 year
old also talks about her future saying
she doesn't want the Big Bang Theory to
end this season like some speculate it
will she actually hopes it will go on
for two more years and after that she
might quit TV Wow but Kaylee won't quit
on love she's made dating equestrian
Carl cook for six months and admits
she's up for getting married again maybe
even quote by the time this magazine
comes out you never know
you